depuis novembre dernier plus de 60 % des
jeunes québécois de 5 à 11 ans ont reçu
au moins une dose du vaccin de pfizer
pour enfin
trois mois plus tard alors que les
masques vont bientôt tomber en classe
une étude américaine vient semer le
doute sur la qualité de leur protection
selon l'étude elle serait presque nul
contre l'infection variant au micro
essentiellement parce qu'il recevrait
une dose trop faible de vaccins et on a
appris avec le temps c'est ce qu'on
commence à apprendre que la petite dose
qu'on donne aux 5 à 11 ans 10
microgrammes que c'est pas assez l'étude
comparé l'efficacité du vaccin files
heures entre deux groupes de jeunes les
12 à 17 ans il y cinq à onze durant la
vague ou micron de décembre à fin
janvier à mesure que le varia progresser
l'efficacité du vaccin chez les 12-17 a
diminué de 66 % à 51 % chez les 5 à 11
ans elle a chuté brutalement de 68 à
seulement 12 % je pense que il ya un
effet de la petite dose qu'on a donnée
chez les 5 à 11 ans et le fait aussi que
c'est juste un vaccin de doses alors que
de plus en plus d'évidence que sébastien
loeb accède à airaines vaccin cours de
l'aco vide c'est des vaccins de trois
doses la bonne nouvelle le vaccin
continue d'offrir aux enfants une
importante protection contre
l'hospitalisation de plus de 70% mais
chez les jeunes d'âge scolaire on le
recommande avant tout pour éviter
l'infection d'enlever les masques à la
vitesse qu'on va le faire à la rentrée
delà de la semaine de relâche je pense
que on se doutait avant que c'était
probablement trop vite que je pense
qu'avec ces données là c'est une
confirmation que c'est probablement
trouvé la santé publique du québec on
reconnaît l'intérêt de l'étude je pense
que le gouvernement pourra prendre acte
de ces résultats là parce que évidemment
si l'efficacité et base ça veut dire
quand valverde masse qui va avoir pas
mal que de transmission par contre pas
question de modifier le programme de
vaccination
je pense que les résultats c'était john
lobb ont changé la stratégie
je crois absolument pas
ma nation d'une troisième dose de vaccin
pour les enfants même pensé le comité
sur l'immunisation qui décédera l'étude
américaine est basée sur les données de
1,2 million de jeunes new yorkais de 5 à
17 ans normand grondin radio canada
montréal